when i look at liberals today  to me they're very comfortable with the  end result of that fear which is that  they're very comfortable with control  with government control they're very  comfortable with government institutions  having a lot of control and even though  even though they don't like big pharma  and they don't like big money in these  institutions when you allied big pharma  with big government and you wound up  having government now have extreme  authority to enforce lockdowns and mass  mandates and vacs mandates that created  a population that was much more  compliant and i think that aids a big  government  modern liberal  because in order to put forth any policy  that they really want right now you need  a compliant population so i really think  that they were very comfortable with the  end game even if not comfortable with  the component of big money in big pharma  that's why i think they laid down and  shut up